how's it goin bro my name is Pippa
welcome to exists or I'm cheating on
clever but I don't give a [ __ ]
sup girl yeah it's working are you doing
hello girl hello girl I'm a boy can't
you [ __ ] I'm a bunny
[ __ ] it I'm a bunny funny tell me not
that ok with funny not that ok with
honey funny and not a hat ok wait honey
Friday what what you don't like pie of
course I like pie
I am beautiful of course I like pie
that's why I can't leave her [ __ ]
face is crazy yeah thank you thank you
that was not a compliment dollars not a
compliment I I think it is a compliment
well you should slap yourself before you
go to sleep oh holy [ __ ] it's very gay
what is this me maybe you should wreck
yourself before you check yourself fool
how dare you talk to me that way don't
you know who I am I done you talk to me
that way don't know you have if I I'm a
bot you must be mistaken
do you ever pick your nose I'm doing it
right now it doesn't [ __ ] look like
it yes they're like the south bikes my
I'm just pointing that out there hmm
show point but sure point but can I slap
you
oh no no Facebook Malik Malik
Facebook Malik Malik Facebook Malik
Malik tell me my future you will become
fat that's right no I won't don't
question me yes you [ __ ] well Dom
requests that may you yeah may yes you
[ __ ] well not 20 questions just a
question game you answer every question
with another question all right tell me
[ __ ] me why you look so sad what I there
don't look sign I'm sorry
hey hey hey I deal with my husband being
deployed with the Marines [ __ ] either
man apparently [ __ ] you got a husband
this is not okay oh you don't want to be
friend with you what so proudly we
hail'd what do you mean with hailed
don't wink at me girl I know what you
mean withheld stop flirting with me wait
I didn't say LP well maybe I lovely and
honorable it is to die for one's country
not really in my opinion hence I'm
clever well why does that mean are you
implying you're more clever than me
because I'm pretty clever you know I
mean I look like clever by ah clever
all right when is your birthday 24th of
October that 24 of a caller back what
thank you I have a question to ask you
about yourself
ask away go do you like to hear it yes
can you get all right well yes but what
is his real name Felix and its first
name Felix
how's that a last name why out B oh
let's do dad need speaker died Dutch of
terrible Donna need to speak it I died
dodged
I died dodged it all makes then I'm not
a computer I am a human being you well
the computer I'll slap you again if I
can do it I don't care if you have that
smug ass face I'll eat your hand
that's disgusting I aced this casting
I'll let you go you're freaking me out
man
fine I'm out of here don't give me that
freak out fine you are not a female does
it look like I have boobs to you this
looks like a big old psycho pax does it
look like her boobs you disturb it
how the hell did she nail light all
right I think it's your job to chat with
people I guess I guess you can say that
don't give me that look you freaked the
[ __ ] out of me Duncan Alex freaked the
[ __ ] out of me
I'm glad you're happy no I don't want to
speak better about it I didn't tell you
to speak better about it don't don't cry
girl what about what what's your problem
seriously that's better
seriously are you [ __ ] what is it
called bipolar it's not my problem
I didn't tell you to because no problem
on the tiger and what about what's your
problem
it's not my problem it's your problem
time how about you and me go and beat up
clever bye alright alright what would
you like to talk about no you get a big
ass wet nation' not you get a big
what I leave me to say that ma'am what
you're not yeah you are okay don't be so
hard on yourself you're not a big ass
but let's get a big-ass weapon and
that's kick clever BOTS balls and chop
them off and you'll eat them afterwards
let's get a big as weapon a kick [ __ ]
about the balls and chopping off and you
leave them afterwards
god damnit hey I never said anything
about Chinese food so you're implying
that Chinese food is chopped off balls
inside what you're saying don't give me
that smile girl do you know about
PewDiePie people die pie you gotta think
about that one know what he doesn't
exist
do you know PewDiePie alright let's see
if she can get this yeah do you like
three to five stop my hey alright do you
like better
[Music]
no are you part of the bro army no [ __ ]
is that supposed to mean
what is yours what is my what well it's
my wife I don't have a wife but I
already love another one I know but you
were the way the one who's hitting on me
I know but you were the one sitting on
it are you sitting on me are you serious
don't smile like that we married of
course I need you
hold on hold on don't give it a like
girl we're not married you need chill
girl when I married you for Jeep that's
right I actually married you for Jeep
it's a good Jeep I can't ever be brave
that's because I married you for a Jeep
that actually oh she's angry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I didn't mean to hurt your
feelings I am you want is that dirt face
but Oh send your face how how I don't
[ __ ] know
I don't [ __ ] know oh [ __ ] that's
amazing that's my life or anything what
do you do for fun I talked to you don't
wake up man don't you dare a good day
Who am I I don't know actually what's
your name oh it says Eva I'm [ __ ] out
my name is cleaver Bert wait you are
cleverbot all this time you are clever
rod
[Music]